a battle used Sabre a piece of
Maryland's Liberty tree the first
newspaper publication of the Declaration
of Independence and even a pair of baby
shoes made from the red coat of a
defeated British soldier those are just
some of the items on display at the
Museum of the American Revolution
opening this week in Philadelphia just
steps away from the Liberty Bell and
Independence Hall this month workers put
the finishing touches on the Museum of
the American Revolution
it took them eight hours to hang this
painting of George Washington at the end
of the war and it's taken them more than
a decade to get to this point well if
you come down here in 2012 collection
director Scott Stevenson gave me a
preview of some of the items that will
go on display this is a British musket a
musket used in the Battle of Lexington
and Concord the first action in the War
of Independence
it would have had a strap a soldier's
canteen one of only three known to have
survived you can see it says US use new
stage new States if you think about it
at this point the United States is still
just an idea right for years the 3,000
items in this collection have been
looking for a permanent home they'll
finally have one amazingly it'll be the
first national museum to tell the entire
story of the American Revolution it's in
a long time coming but I'm glad it's
here Brown University professor Gordon
wood is a scholar of the Revolution
museums for almost every conceivable
event in American history or person in
American history but not for the
American Revolution which is
extraordinary when you think of the
Revolution as the most important event
in our history the museum's collection
will include this letter written in
Washington's own hand celebrating the
French joining the cause that's a pretty
exciting guy that's a nice thing to have
and this document this is the original
this is the original in the spring of
1775 an enlistment form for recruits to
an uprising and enlist ourselves as
soldiers in the Massachusetts service
for the preservation of the liberties of
America this is the beginning of the
army this is it the carvings on a
soldier's Powderhorn show the stakes
were high kill or be killed and liberty
or death the museum will also feature
the phases of the Revolution pictures
taken of Revolutionary War veterans
during the earliest days of photography
some of these former soldiers were more
than a hundred years old when they posed
for these pictures is this the prize of
the collection really
it would be hard to top this one that's
for sure the 20-foot piece of canvas was
General Washington's home during the war
this is his actual tent this is it this
is the roof under which he spent at
least half of the American Revolution
personally I think it's chilling to
think about the emotions that were felt
underneath this canvas now out of
storage the tent is up again this time
not on the fields of Valley Forge
but behind a layer of thick protective
glass Washington's victories led to the
birth of a nation to be an American is
to not be somebody but to believe in
something and the things we believe in
came out of that revolution the story is
written only in this collection
artifacts of an act of defiance would
literally change the world and the
museum opens on April 19th that's the
240 second anniversary of the battles of
Lexington and Concord the first
confrontations of the Revolutionary War
so far more than 30,000 tickets have
been sold to the museum very exciting
this has finally happened to things I
didn't realize one is muskets are
gigantic yes and heavy very very big and
George Washington's tent is so well
preserved and looks almost whimsical
like a circus tent when put on I know
now what I expected at all at all in the
field of battle but amazing that they
have all that art those artifacts well
the museum the American ticket